j'avais une patiente qui me disaient mes
amis me disent de partir en vacances
d'aller voir des films comiques mais se
rendent pas compte je peux être déprimé
partout n'importe où avec n'importe qui
[Musique]
à
lorsqu'on a un proche qui souffre de
maladie dépressive
on navigue entre deux écueils trop
l'écouté et trop le secouer
[Musique]
bien sûr il faut écouter la personne
dépressive parce que c'est important
qu'ils puissent raconter toutes les
souffrances qu'elle ressent à
l'intérieur d'elle il ya une vraie
souffrance morale et donc écouter
comprendre cette souffrance est
important mais il ne faut pas l'écouter
au point d'adhérer à sa vision du monde
la personne déprimée elle pense qu' elle
ne guérira pas que c'est foutu que c'est
de sa faute ou de la faute que je ne
sais quoi en fait elle a des visions du
monde qui a un peu toxique pour elle
même et c'est important de ne pas
absorber cette vision du monde donc on
écoute on soutient on encourage on
montre qu'on est là mais on ne se laisse
pas aspirer soi-même dans la dépression
[Musique]
le port voilà agressé la personne ne
bouge toi secoue toi elle ne peut pas si
elle est déprimée elle a beaucoup de mal
s'il bouge et où elle peut le faire un
tout petit peu puis tout va se casser la
figure
rapidement mais pour autant sans aller
jusqu'à là ce coup et c'est important de
la stimuler puisqu'on sait qu'une des
manières d'aider les personnes déprimées
c'est de leur proposer de se bouger mais
de les accompagner
c'est leur dire que finalement entre une
heure passée dans le canapé à regarder
des vidéos ou des écrans et une heure à
marcher dans la forêt est bien dans le
premier cas elle aggrave leur dépression
et dans le deuxième cas elle n'améliore
le problème qu'ont les personnes
déprimées lorsqu'on leur propose de les
accompagner dans les activités agréable
puisque c'est ça qu'il faut faire à
leurs côtés leur proposer de sortir de
bouger d'aller au cinéma
le problème qu'elles vont avoir c'est
que ça ne leur fera pas plaisir et donc
elles vont vous dire ouais mais bon je
me sens pas mieux après l'avoir fait et
c'est vrai à court terme et à long terme
et répétait ses efforts va les aider
c'est ça qu'on doit leur dire on pourra
leur dire on fait pas ça pour que tu te
sentes mieux d'un coup de baguette
magique on fait ça pour que tu ne
continue pas à décembre et a pas
enfermée contre son gré évidemment dans
ces cercles vicieux de la dépression
puisqu'il naciri au cercle il y à un
cercle vicieux dans la dépression - j'en
fais plus je me dévaloriser plus ça me
déprime de n'être capable de rien faire
plus ça me déprime
moi j'ai envie de faire des choses je
suis démotivé je pense que ça ne servira
à rien donc l'entourage peut aider la
personne déprimée à interrompre à casser
ce cercle vicieux parce que toute seule
elle a du mal